andré retient le cidre oui oui alors oui
moi ce que j'ai fait plus dangereux dans
ma vie c'était toujours pour
impressionner les filles quand j'étais
ado est donc en forêt il s'entraîne plus
un jour on est alors attention
il date juste m'étais juste 11 ans alors
bien sûr un liner tristesse alors qu'est
ce qu'il a fait et donc en forêt de
fontainebleau il ya des rochers donc on
partait avec des amis les parents de
déposer et donc pour impressionner une
fille qui s'appelait isabelle a été
magnifique toutes les abeilles sont
belles déjà et j'avais fait de la
varappe c'est-à-dire l'escaladent de
roches à mains nues et donc j'ai
escaladé un rocher mais gigantesque qui
s'était dit m et au milieu du rocher à 5
m j'ai été complètement bloquée à
tétanisées par l'angoissé il affirmé oui
donc je disais ouais ça va aller
t'inquiète isabelle ans et il a fallu
que des équipes de cordis arrive pour
sortir de là cinq mètres plantée au
milieu du rosaire fontainebleau a été
d'ailleurs isabelle eux n'est devenu
isabelle à la belle est jamais sortie
avec quels partis frères allaient porter
qu'un mec qui faisait vraiment
d'escaladé brega n'aurait grimpeur voilà
ça vous regarde et lui oui qu'est ce que
vous avez fait de plus dangereux
moi j'ai loué un petit bateau sans
permis à feu les grosses et je me suis
encastrée dans les rochers parce qu'en
fait j'ai laissé lancre un peu trop tard
et avec le courant j'ai été non la jtg
super peur on est venu me rappelle enfin
j'ai été rapatrié mais vraiment avec un
hélicoptère est tout sauf ça c'est super
dangereux j'ai eu vraiment la peur de ma
vie
bah écoute et pédalos de pas non plus
qu'est ce que c'est un accident de
pédalos sais pas non plus ne fait pas
vraiment avancer une douve oméga
vraiment on les compte sur les doigts
d'une volée mais il est comme ça
aujourd'hui
vraiment vous qui souhaitez le plus
dangereux alors il ya plusieurs choses
mais mon cou avec vous ah oui notamment
tu sais quand on est à la hausse
on est allé inscrire en italie et que
vous m'avez faire une course de chiens
de traîneaux colis chez nous
3e mi-temps france était bonne et on ne
sait pas ce qu'on attend d'une attaque
et macarons des militants du palu est en
france vous semblez vous n'avez pas si
l'italie cela dit les chiens de
traîneaux il fallait se tenir debout
derrière ça vous a glissé et que les
chiens ils sont partis à toute vitesse
et que j'avais brac qui sont allongés 10
centimes est en fait sont ils ont tourné
à droite pour rejoindre leur mère et moi
pareil et j'ai cru allez me dire police
qui hurlait vous allez me labi mais vous
allez me la bible on y reste en quoi
c'est vrai que j'ai eu peur alors
franchement j'ai très très fort j'écoute
les chiens n'avaient jamais me ramener